ja was mein thema ist ich engagiere mich
jetzt seit einer woche mit unserer
aktion helden helfen dafür dass die so
genannten land verteidiger in der
ukraine besser ausgestattet werden wir
haben momentan wir haben die situation
es gibt die erste reihe wo die
soldatinnen und soldaten der
ukrainischen armee stehen und die zweite
reihe die freiwilligen leute die einfach
einen gewehr in die hand bekommen haben
und als freiwillige als land verteidiger
dort so nennen sie zur verfügung stehen
und gegen die schweren geschütze der
russischen armee kämpfen und ich muss
sagen ich wünsche mir dass auch diese
menschen gerade viele kommen aus unseren
jugendorganisationen viele mit denen ich
persönlich befreundet bin dass sie
besser ausgestattet werden deswegen
sollte der bund und die länder mehr
schutzwesten liefern es sollten mehr
schutzkleidung geliefert werden wir als
junge union haben die aktion gestartet
und haben dort schon einigen den ersten
konvoi hingebracht der zweite ist gerade
auf dem weg und es braucht dringend für
diese leute mehr unterstützung weil sie
sind den angriffen artillerie oder auch
sprengsätzen einfach schutzlos
ausgeliefert dafür setze ich mich all
das fordere ich von der bundes und von
der landesregierung
wenig wie empfinden sie die sagt ja ich
kann mich nur anschließen denn das was
herr gruber noch gesehen hatten gespürt
hat es kommt darauf an dass die über
100.000
menschen die sich jetzt freiwillig
gemeldet haben um das land zu
verteidigen
sie bekommen zwar ein maschinengewehr
ein kalaschnikow in der hand gedrückt
und dann eine kurze schulung aber an
schutzwesten
feldes helme und andere ausrüstung weil
das natürlich nicht im budget vorgesehen
weil wir haben uns nicht auf einen krieg
vorbereitet der mehr ist mehr oder
weniger gut gerüstet aber nicht all die
menschen die jetzt da am blog posten
stehen die versuchen auch diese
sabotagen gruppen zu vernichten und das
sind auch meine freunde also botschaft
die noch vor kurzem hier in europa tätig
waren schicken mir bilder sie haben auch
ein maschinengewehr sie stellen oder sie
kontrollieren die straßen in der nacht
so sieht der alltag aus heute in der
ukraine mitten in europa und deswegen
danke vielmals koopmann für für dieser
initiative wir hoffen dass auch die
bundesregierung dass die länder uns
unterstützen es fehlt ist ein mangelware
muss man sagen schon sichere westen ist
wirklich eine mangelware geld ist zwar
da aber das zu finden ist nicht so
einfach und aber jede schutzweste zählte
und ich habe gerade vorgestern einen
anruf bekommen aus michael reif einer
stadt im süden sie ist umzingelt und
und der bürgermeister ruft verzweifelt
brauche 3000 schutzwesten weil sonst ich
die stadt nicht verteidigen kann weil
die russen die truppen forderten und das
ist alltag der menschen heute wenn wir
mit ihnen sprechen und die leute müssen
ausladung in integrierte es kommt schnee
und sie brauchen diese unterstützung aus
deutschland deswegen vielen dank und
deswegen glaube ich auch wir müssen bei
uns die polizei bestände prüfen und wir
müssen auch da den da bin ich wirklich
beim regel ihr sind ich habe in den
letzten tagen einige gespräche geführt
da sagen mir leute wir haben
ausgemusterte westen in deutschland die
sind ausgemustert weil man nicht mehr
für die sicherheit garantieren können
dort sind menschen komplett schutzlosen
da kann es doch nicht mehr um
ausgemustert gehen da müssen die sachen
hin und die volt da wollen leute in
deutschland diese diese westen
vernichten weil sie ausgemustert sind
das wäre einfach nicht mein kopf rein
muss ich wirklich sagen da müssen wir
dringend und schnell handeln ich
bewundere das was thema kuban macht mit
seiner aktion wir bei bild herz für
kinder ist ja auch eine
organisation die extrem jetzt hilft aber
ich frage mich herr botschafter welt
höre auch ihre schilderungen sind sie
eigentlich manchmal selbst überrascht
über den kampfesmut ihrer landsleute
oder haben sie erwartet dass die so
reagieren wenn putin kommt und ich hatte
keine zweifel dass die deutschen haben
immer noch zweifel an uns das ist das
was ich auch jetzt im politischen berlin
der zwölfte tag des krieges und man
räumt uns immer noch kaum eine chance
dass wir diesen krieg überleben können
dass wir nicht verlieren und wir dürfen
diesen krieg nicht verlieren und
deswegen das was an uns liegt wir werden
alles tun und er wird gekämpft auch wenn
es vielleicht keine waffen mehr gibt
dann wenn wir das verlieren wenn wir
unsere heimat verlieren dann wird sie
nicht mehr zu gewinnen seien dann dann
werden menschen verjagt menschen
gefoltert menschen im kz geschichte
ähnlich wie in belarus wie in russland
selbst das wollen wir nicht und deswegen
es geht um das schiere überleben als
staat als volk und deswegen stellt sich
auch die frage gar nicht ob wir uns
wehren oder nicht manche würden
vielleicht schon uns wünschen okay wir
können diese schreckliche bilder gar
nicht mehr ertragen das was wir sehen
aber dann gefallen werden wir nicht tun
dass die deutschen diese bilder nicht
mehr sehen weil wir uns nicht erlauben
können einfach so stoppt und zu sagen
okay ein kompromiss machen dass kate
nicht putin will keine kompromisse er
will die ukraine besetzen und vernichten
und darum geht es und deswegen auch in
unserer strophe der hymne die erste
strophe heißt noch ist die ukraine nicht
gestorben das heißt es ist so man man
kämpft weil das eigentlich teil der dna
der ukraine ist zu kämpfen weil wir
unsere staatlichkeit viel zu oft
verlieren mussten und wir dürfen das
heute nichts tun wir dürfen die heimat
nicht verlieren und ich glaube wir
sollten uns schon auch jeder der in
deutschland der daran zweifelt ob wir zu
viel tun ob wir im endeffekt zu viel
sanktionen auch die natürlich auch als
bumerang nach deutschland zurückkommen
jeder der meint es wäre falsch dass wir
waffen auch die ukraine liefert er
sollte sich eine frage stellen nämlich
die frage während wir eigentlich auch so
mutig werden wir eigentlich auch bereit
unser land so in diesem maße zu
verteidigen wie das diejenigen in der
ukraine
unsere freundinnen und freunde gerade
tun und nur wer diese frage mit ja
beantwortet der darf weiter kritik üben
aus meiner sicht ist dann haben wir
nicht auch die umkehr frage herr kuban
wer auch bereit wäre das zu tun ist für
alle sanktionen auflief autozone und
allem drum und dran was damit
mitschwingt am ende ist es eine
abwägungsfrage und ich habe ja schon
gesagt wir sind da auch nicht alleine
auf dieser im westen wir sind ein
wesentlicher teil des westens aber der
westen kann nur gemeinsam agieren und
wir müssen am ende für eine notlösung
genauso wie auch für andere maßnahmen
wie auch für die frage des embargos wenn
es wirklich richtig hilfreich sein soll
dann müssen wir dafür eben die anderen
partner wie die europäische union und
wie auch die amerikaner an unserer seite
haben das gehört zur wahrheit einfach
dazu die deutschen können das bewegen
die deutschen können einen prozess
pushen das haben wir in der
vergangenheit sie haben das thema swift
vorhin angesprochen der botschafter zu
wenig getan da waren wir eher zögerlich
ich hielte das für falsch
und wir sollten bei dieser stelle mehr
voranschreiten aber wir müssen es
gemeinsam mit den europäischen partnern
und amerikanern touren nur so ist
wirksam ein mann bei dem ich weiß dass
seine worte nicht nur worte sind sondern
dass er den auch wirklich taten folgen
lassen würde je nachdem wie putin sich
entscheidet ist paul ronzheimer und
deswegen möchte ich die sendung gerne
wieder in alter tradition mit dir auch
beenden und die schilderung von deinem
heutigen kriegstag und was du erlebt
hast
janina das was ich heute in dem vorort
von kiel sehen konnte ist etwas was auf
die ganze ukraine zurollt nämlich eine
komplette zerstörung eine vernichtung
des lebens menschen die ihre häuser
verlassen müssen menschen die freunde
familie kinder verlieren menschen die
schon auf der flucht waren die ein
gepäckstück dabei hatten auf der straße
waren die von einer rakete putins
getroffen werden
wie deutsche dürfen da nicht einfach
zuschauen aus meiner sicht wir müssen
endlich verstehen was dort passiert und
so handeln jeder tag an dem wir nichts
tun und dem die sanktion lasch sind
machen uns mitschuldig mit dem was ich
hier sehe und die menschen gehen gerade
jetzt ins bett ist es eine
geister stimmung es ist ruhiger als
sonst das macht aber viele nervös weil
alle wissen putin wird nicht aufhören
damit zumindest nicht so wirklich
aufhören hier die menschen zu
bombardieren er wird nicht aufhören das
sirenengeheul in allen städten der
ukraine zu hören ist und er wird nicht
aufhören zivilisten zu bombardieren denn
das ist ein ziel angst und terror zu
verbreiten und er will die ukraine dazu
bringen dass sie staat nicht mehr
existent ist und das was ich hier heute
in kiew erlebt habe droht in vielen
städten und passiert in vielen städten
den haag tief in anderen in allen großen
der ukraine ich kann nur unsere
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer bitten
schauen sie weiterhin schauen sie was
hier passiert